بيان نعي القاده الشهداء للشعب
والامه من المؤمنين رجال صدقوا ما عاهدوا
الله
عليه فمنهم من قضى نحبه ومنهم من ينتظر
وما بدلوا
تبديلا بكل معاني الفخر والاعتزاز
وبمزيد من الايمان والاصرار
على مواصله درب
الشهداء ننعى الى شعبنا الفلسطيني في كل
ساحات الوطن
وخارجه وامتنا العربيه والاسلاميه واحرار
العالم القائد
المجاهد والقامه الوطنيه
الكبيره الشهيد الشيخ صالح العاروري ابو
محمد نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه
حماس قائد الحركه في الضفه
الغربيه واخوانه
القاده القائد القسامي سمير فندي ابو
عامر والقائد القسامي عزام الاقرع ابو
عمار وعدد من اخوانهم من كوادر وابناء
الحركه وهم
الاخ الشهيد محمود زكي
شاهين والاخ الشهيد محمد
بشاشه والاخ الشهيد محمد
الريس والاخ الشهيد احمد
حمود الذين ارتقوا الى ربهم
شهداء مساء اليوم
الثلاثاء في
العاصمه اللبنانيه
بيروت اثر عمليه اغتيال
جبانه نفذها العدو
الصهيوني في عدوان همجي وجريمه
نكراء تثبت مجددا دمويته التي يمارسها على
شعبنا في غزه
والضفه والخارج وفي كل
مكان ابناء شعبنا
المجاهد نؤكد ان اغتيال الاحتلال
الصهيوني للاخ القائد الوطني الكبير
المجاهد الشيخ صالح
العاروري واخوانه من قاده الحركه وكوادرها
على الاراضي اللبنانيه هو عمل
ارهابي مكتمل
الاركان وانتهاك لسياده
لبنان وتوسي سع لدائره عدوانه على شعبنا
وامتنا
ويتحمل مسؤوليه
تداعياته الاحتلال الصهيوني
النازي ولن
يفلح في كسر اراده الصمود
والمقاومه لدى شعبنا ومقاومته
الباسله لقد امتزجت الدماء الطاهره القائد
الشهيد الشيخ صالح العاروري
واخوانه مع دماء عشرات
الالاف من شهداء شعبنا
وجرحاه في قطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه
والخارج ودماء شهداء الامه في معركه طوفان
الاقصى من اجل
فلسطين
والقدس والاقصى
لقد مضى القائد
الشيخ صالح العاروري واخوانه الى ربهم
شهداء بعد حياه
حافله بالتضحيه والجهاد
والمقاومه والعمل في كل
ساحات وفي كل
الميادين من اجل
فلسطين ومن اجل كرامه الشعب وسياده هذه
الامه
وفي القلب منها القدس والمسجد الاقصى
المبارك ونالوا اسمى امانيهم على درب ذات
الشوكه وتركوا من خلفهم رجالا
اشداء يحملون الرايه من بعدهم ويكملون
المسيره دفاعا عن شعبنا وارضنا
ومقدساتنا حتى التحرير والعوده باذن
الله وان حركه تقدم قادتها
ومؤسسيها
شهداء من اجل كرامه شعبنا
وامتنا لن تهزم ابدا باذن الله بل تزيدها
هذه
الاستهدافات قوه وصلابه وعزيمه لا
تلين هذا هو تاريخ
المقاومه
والحركه بعد اغتيال قادتها انها اشد قوه
واصرار تقبل الله القائد
الشهيد الشيخ ابا محمد واخوانه
ورفاقه واسكنهم الفردوس الاعلى من
الجنه الى الله في
الخالدين مع النبيين والصديق والشهداء
والصالحين وحسن اولئك رفيقا وانه
لجهاد نصر او استشهاد والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته